Just before we get into the video let me thank
today’s sponsor Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community
for creators, with thousands of classes in
design, business and more.
I’ve talked about Skillshare a few times
on this channel, and mentioned the various
courses and things I’ve learned on that
platform.
But, maybe you haven't got Skillshare yet,
and you are totally skill-less.
That's a great shame because there are thousands
classes on skillshare for you to level up
your design, business, video, social media,
whatever skills.
(Or just take them from nothing to something,
you can do that to).
Me?
I've taken video production courses, camera
courses, YouTubey stuff, I also want to squeeze
out as much as possible from my day so I watched
this course by a guy called Thomas Frank (also
a YouTuber) on getting more stuff done in
a day - great stuff, worth checking out if
you want to get more done in a day!
But yes, Skillshare, just go do it.
You'll like it.
It's also free for 2 months so you can try
it out, and I’m pretty sure you’ll continue
your membership because its so great.
Support Visual Politik by supporting Skillshare!
There is a link below which will let you use
the platform for 2 months for free!
And let's get into it.
It’s a fact, China is hot right now.
The Beijing regime’s influence over the
world has never been as great as it is today,
and the same applies to China's fame and presence
in global media.
And, you know what?
The person responsible for all this is this
man.
Xi Jinping has become the Chinese president
with the most power since the fall of Mao
Zedong.
He came to power in 2013 with two great promises:
on the one hand, to expand China's power and
influence over the world, and on the other,
to consolidate the communist party’s political
power.
That way, the Chinese president seeks to end
the widespread belief that economic development
is always followed by political transitions
and democratic processes.
But folks, to achieve his goals and consolidate
his power, Xi Jinping first needs to remove
two large pebbles from his shoe, two pebbles
he perceives as a threat to China’s cohesion
and national identity:
I’m talking about Taiwan and Hong Kong.
And it’s precisely the second one, Hong
Kong, which we’ll talk about in this video.
As you probably all know, Hong Kong is currently
experiencing the greatest civil protests since
the end of British colonization, and they
might also become the longest protests.
The trigger?: The Extradition Law.
You see, this law proposed by Hong Kong’s
Chief Executive, Carrie Lam, following Beijing’s
directives, would allow for the extradition
of Hong Kong citizens to be tried and, if
applicable, imprisoned in mainland China.
In other words, this proposed Law would recognize
the validity of the courts controlled by the
Chinese Communist Party.
And even though in the end, after pressure
from the protesters, the proposed Law was
withdrawn, it’s a clear example of how things
are working in Hong Kong.
But why was this particular proposal the last
straw for the people of Hong Kong?
What does Carrie Lam's proposal mean?
Are we witnessing a historical turning point
in the relationship between the former colony
and China?
Listen up.
(THE EXTRADITION LAW, THE STRAW THAT BROKE
THE CAMEL’S BACK)
That's right, the Extradition Law is the proverbial
straw that broke the camel’s back.
Because... don’t think it all began with
this legislation, not at all.
Beijing's interference in Hong Kong politics
and the promotion of pro-Chinese laws by Hong
Kong authorities – which actually emanate
from the continental regime itself, from the
Chinese regime itself – have been somewhat
constant since the United Kingdom transferred
Hong Kong back to China in 1997.
Want an example?
Well, check this out.
Let's go back to the year 2003.
Just six years after its transfer to China,
the Hong Kong executive proposed the so-called
National Security Law, which sought to ban
and punish pro-independence movements.
Beijing was seeking, and I say seeking because
the Law was repealed, to shield its sovereignty
over the territory and stamp out any scrap
of opposition.
However, it didn’t let a small obstacle
get in its way, China ran into fierce opposition
from Hong Kong’s citizens, who took to the
streets, leading to the greatest protests
in Hong Kong’s history...
Until now....
Yes, folks, because the protests of this year,
2019, have already far exceeded those of 2003.
And the truth is that there are plenty of
reasons why.
Imagine that you live in a territory with
an independent economic system, guaranteed
justice and a society with a lot of freedoms
such as, free access to the internet and social
networks.
And, suddenly, a dictatorial regime with which
you don’t identify at all, a regime where
none of these rights and freedoms exist and
where justice is controlled by a single party,
seeks to impose a Law that would allow them
to extradite you to be judged under that regime
with its conditions, what would you do?
Discontent and anger seem more than justified,
don't you think?
After all, the extradition law, even though
it apparently doesn’t specifically mention
political opposition,, marks the end of Hong
Kong's model and autonomy.
Because of course...
Don’t tell me it’s hard to imagine a Chinese
court asking for the extradition of a dissident
or a political opponent from Hong Kong for
any reason.
Right?
( Hong Kong extradition law is a death sentence
for Hong Kong, says exiled bookseller Lam
Wing-kee.
“Beijing will use this law to control Hong
Kong completely.
Freedom of speech will be lost.
In the past, the regime kidnapped its critics,
like me, illegally.
With this law, they will abduct their critics
legally.”
Hong Kong Free Press)
Well, the fact is that the discontent is so
great that according to a recent study of
the Public Opinion Program of the University
of Hong Kong, rejection of China had never
been as strong among Hong Kong citizens as
it is now.
But that’s not all.
The worst is the general feeling that the
Hong Kong executive responds to China’s
interests and not those of its own local citizens.
And that’s a problem in a territory where
citizens cannot change things because the
truth is that democracy doesn’t exist.
In Hong Kong not all citizens are allowed
to vote and the government chief executive
himself is proposed by Beijing.
You see, in a normal, democratic and free
country, if a ruler does badly, if he or she
rules against the people’s interests or
is discovered favoring other interests, people
stop voting for that person or that party,
and then they can start undoing the bad policies.
However, that can’t happen here.
After transferring the territory’s sovereignty
to China, the political system turned into
something very, very similar to a corporatist
regime that governs for the interests of two
powerful hands:
On the one hand that of the Chinese iron fist
and on the other, the money-filled hands of
the great businessmen that favor Beijing;
especially those of the great real estate
tycoons that have managed to form an oligopoly
where Hong Kong is nothing more than a captive
market that acts at their service.
Surprised?
Well… you shouldn’t be.
In fact, the Hong Kong political system feeds
this model, a lot.
In fact, we’ve already talked about this
in a previous video where we tell you why
Hong Kong has the most expensive housing in
the world.
The point is that in Hong Kong, the Chief
Executive – the governmental leader – is
elected by the members of the Election Committee,
which has about 1,200 people.
And... who chooses those 1,200 representatives?
Well, to be honest, it’s easier to start
by counting those who don’t vote: the citizens.
We’re talking about a very complicated system
in which sectoral organizations, religious
leaders, business leaders, unions and even
companies participate.
All orchestrated to endorse China’s power.
For example, check out what’s happening
with the agriculture sector, which is traditionally
connected to Beijing.
Despite only involving 0.1% of Hong Kong’s
economy, farmers hold more weight in the Election
Committee than much, much more important sectors
such as the financial sector.
As you can see, it’s all very democratic,
right?.
In fact, the lack of democracy is the real
reason behind the current protests and behind
many past protests.
Because, in spite of the fact that democracy
doesn’t technically exist, Hong Kong is
and has been a regional epicenter of political
activism and dissent against Beijing for decades.
And the Law of Extradition was the last straw
in a process that is spelling the end of all
those freedoms.
If you think about it, it’s the most dramatic
part of it.
In Hong Kong we aren’t facing a dictatorship
that wants to get its way, we’re witnessing
people who are used to living in freedom,
and who are watching that freedom slip away
every day.
And that explains what comes next, listen
up.
(THE TRIPLE FREEDOM, DOWNHILL WITH NO BRAKES)
That's right folks, in Hong Kong the three
freedoms are in free fall.
Economic, individual and political freedom,
all three, have worsened since China took
over in 1997.
And that has consequences on every level.
Especially in a place that has been traditionally
known for its scrupulous respect for legal
certainty and institutional stability.
And that’s precisely why around 1,500 multinational
companies have their Asian headquarters in
Hong Kong.
However, folks, all this may end badly.
Not only in the political field, but also
in the economic field.
China’s continuous interference is, in many
cases, translating into serious, very serious
violations of several companies’ legal safety.
In the economic field, China has increased
its blackmailing of private companies so they’ll
maintain a critical stance against any movement
that opposes Beijing.
That is, if they don't want to have any trouble
staying in the big Chinese market.
That’s what happened, for example, with
the Hong Kong airline Cathay Pacific, which
suffered the consequences of not being “critical”
during the protests against the Extradition
Lawand not sufficiently controlling its workers’
political expressions.
(Cathay Pacific replaces chief executive as
China ups pressure over protests.
Financial Times )
(Cathay Pacific staff speak of climate of
fear.
BBC)
(Cathay Pacific employees say they fear losing
their jobs if they express support for pro-democracy
protesters in Hong Kong.
Some are considering bringing decoy mobiles
with them in case their phones are checked
on arrival in the mainland.)
But no, it doesn’t end there.
Folks, the repression of the business sector,
of the productive sectors, is even reaching
cases of boycotts, organized by the Chinese
government itself through social networks.
And nobody’s safe, not even bubble tea.
(Bubble tea brawl: Taiwan brands face mainland
boycott over Hong Kong gesture.
Reuters)
Worst of all, we aren’t even talking about
small isolated cases.
Not at all.
Xi Jinping knows that he runs a country that
has one of the most desired markets for any
company worth its salt.
An overwhelmingly huge population, a growing
middle class and consumer power that is already
at exorbitant levels.
To be in business in China is to be close
to success, and Xi knows that this is something
he can leverage to politically press people,
by using commerce and the business sector.
And that obviously doesn’t reassure any
company.
One misstep... and...
Also, how on earth are they going to control
their employees?
How can they limit the freedom of expression
of others?
How can they attract international talent
with such conditions?
Anyway, it starts with bubble tea, and ends
with any company that doesn’t do what China
wants, and of course, this isn’t just reprehensible,
it’s irresponsible.
China’s attitude, along with the blatant
protection of local oligarchs and the submission
of the local government are ending Hong Kong's
prosperity.
The people of Hong Kong feel like they’re
not only losing their political freedoms,
but also their own economic well-being.
Because if Hong Kong loses its independence,
legal certainty and neutrality, what’s left?
Folks, the worst part is that Hong Kong may
simply stop being Hong Kong.
Surely now you may better understand why the
protests happened and why they’re lasting
so long.
Hong Kong’s society feels like it’s facing
one of its last chances to fight back.
It’s now or never.
But if you want to know why Xi Jinping is
so interested in Hong Kong, and why, despite
all of this, China still needs this small
territory, stay tuned because we’ll bring
more videos about Hong Kong in which we’ll
explain these and many other things.
But now it's your turn, do you think that
the pressure of the people of Hong Kong will
help them regain their political and individual
freedoms?
Will China be able to squash Hong Kong's languishing
political freedom?
Is this the beginning of the end of Hong Kong
as we know it?
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.